for those of you who haven't heard
Amazon have recently acquired the rights
from the Tolkien estate to begin filming
a laws of the Rings TV show they'll be
working with New Line Cinema
HarperCollins and the Tolkien estate to
bring us a multi-season project with the
budget of around a hundred to one
hundred and fifty million dollars a
season it's likely that we're gonna get
a fantasy series to rival all that have
come before not much has been said in
regards to the direction of the show's
plot but we are led to believe that the
show will be a prequel to the Lord of
the Rings this does make sense as so
much happens before the Fellowship of
the Ring that some of our lingering
questions may finally be answered
Tolkien had a vast selection of work
both finished and unfinished to choose
from so let's go through a few possible
storylines that they could follow and
some that I'd like to see the origin
story of Sauron and the One Ring we all
know Sauron as the evil catalyst behind
most of the events in middle-earth the
eye that watches over Mordor but Sauron
was not always known as the evil one he
once went by the name of an ATAR Lord of
the gift and was trusted by men dwarves
and even elves he crafted nine rings of
power for the kings of men seven for the
Dwarven Lords and one for himself to
control all other rings unknown lita
Sauron Kella Brimble somewhat of an
apprentice to him whom he taught how to
craft rings of power made three rings
for the elves and hid them from saurons
corruption
when Sauron found out about these hidden
rings he was furious as he was not able
to control them
the elves now aware of sarang's true
name and nature went to war resulted in
the death of Kelly Brimble
and Sauron being forced to retreat to
the darkest corners of Mordor being able
to see the story behind Sauron and how
he manipulated the many races of
middle-earth with the rings of power
would make for a great TV series and
would satisfy the curiosity of many fans
it could feature characters that we
already know such as Elrond and
Galadriel and would show us what the
Dwarven and elvish kingdoms used to look
like this is personally my favorite idea
and where I hope they go with the TV
show the story of Elendil and his Silla
door this story would take place almost
1500 years of the war with Kelly bramble
and the elves Sauron returns but during
an attack on Mordor he is captured by
the king of númenor during his time as a
prisoner
Sauron manages to deceive the king and
begins to use him as a puppet he
convinces him to attack Valinor the land
to the west with the Immortals and the
gods of middle-earth inhabit the land
that Sauron was once exiled from their
attack on Valinor is a complete failure
and arrrooo the creator of the world
sinks their fleet and their homeland of
númenor under the sea a lindo and his
sealed door the ancestors of Aragorn
managed to escape and they found the
kingdoms of Arnall and Gondor
sauron master sees our me once again and
returns to fight the forces of elves and
men during this battle Olinda was killed
but a SIL door does defeat Sauron claim
in the One Ring as his own
despite Aaron's attempts to persuade his
little dog to destroy the ring he falls
to its seduction and keeps it he would
eventually be killed in an ambush and
the ring would be lost for thousands of
years until Gollum would find it this
story would undoubtedly make for an epic
viewing experience and would focus on
the history of men in middle-earth the
only problem of this story is that large
parts have already been told during the
intro of the Fellowship of the Ring
there are some stories that are worth an
honourable mention the children of
holdin the book takes place in what is
considered to be tokens first age and is
seen as some of his darkest material it
follows the children of a hero named
Horan particularly his son Torian the
story features great evil beings dragons
and even a bit of incest for you Game of
Thrones fans out there the story of
Beren and lúthien is one of tokens most
well known works outside of Lord of the
Rings and it's a story about the
forbidden love between a man named Baron
and a royal elf named lúthien in order
to marry lúthien Baron is tasked with
retrieving the crown of Morgoth sour ons
old master the story follows his
impossible task and we see elements that
we are not used to such as werewolves
and vampires
and lastly the story of Aragorn
Aragorn is undoubtedly one of the fan
favorites but when we meet him in a
Fellowship of the Ring
he's already well into his 80s and not
much is mentioned about his prior life a
story following young Aragorn
as he grows and becomes the man we've
all come to expect would please many
fans and the story could even include
other favorites such as Gandalf and
Legolas but I feel like this is the
least likely of all the options we've
discussed today as this story is a bit
too similar to the Fellowship of the
Ring despite the direction Amazon decide
to take the franchise in it is
guaranteed to have a hefty budget and
they do genuinely seem to care about the
project we can only hope they don't
deviate too far from the books and treat
Tolkien's work with the respect it
deserves
what about you guys what timelines and
stories would you like to see and does
the prospect of a lautering
TV show even excite you